hey everyone welcome to simulation we
are now sitting down with the Beth Ben
Donato thanks for coming on thanks for
having me
really appreciate it so drive AI yes and
you're doing electrical engineering
there yes so we're adding a bunch of
sensors to cars and we are programming
the car to drive autonomously that is
correct
nice and so long as drive a I've been
around now three years three years okay
and so what's going on is we're doing
lidar we're doing cameras on the car and
we're programming it you said to go from
one place one popular place to another
popular place as a shuttle yes we have a
deployment in July and Frisco Texas
Frisco Texas okay yes and so this sort
of the deployment the all this work has
been going up to this deployment so if
it's a shuttle then it must be a larger
vehicle it is it's like a little van
it's it's kind of actually what it is
it's the New York taxi so it's a it's
like a little it's a Nissan van it's
like seven people know it no it's it's
it would have five five okay so there's
like cargo space in the back and then
there's room for three not to big people
in the middle and then there's you know
a driver and a passenger okay okay and
so why first of all they use their
mountain view we are in Mountain View it
turns out that in Texas they're a little
more eager to have autonomous vehicles
on their public roads and the the city
of Frisco in particular has a
transportation problem that they're
trying to solve and which is moving
these people between these different
spots in Texas it's really hot and
people don't necessarily want to walk to
go to lunch or to go shopping or
whatever and it's kind of a pain to take
your car and it's so it's you know a
shuttle is something that's really going
to solve a problem and we're very
excited to
that problem for them okay
so it's a combination of it being hot a
combination of there being a lot of
passenger vehicles already on the street
I don't know if that's so much of a
problem I think I think parking I think
it's it's not really that far away and
just the hassle of going to get your car
and then finding parking and then going
back it's just it would just be so much
easier to just you know you and your
co-workers just go over to the mall for
lunch and then go back and it's just
wait you know way less hassle that makes
sense okay so we're talking maybe a
company of a couple hundred or a couple
thousand people is especially around
noon all wanting to go to lunch and then
they're shuttled over to a center that
has a lot of right I believe there's
thousands of employees at this office
park yeah okay okay and see that that
makes a lot of sense rather than
everybody getting in their own car and
driving over five cars and it's just a
shuttle service and it also makes it
easier to program because then you get
one route programmed right it's it's a
very good beginning for us to you know
enter this new city and you're right we
can you know we can define where the
stops are going to be where it makes
sense where it's safe for passengers to
get on and off and it's you know you
know good for our vehicle to be able to
you know to get to that spot and to know
ahead of time that you know these are
the four or five spots where we could
stop yeah so there's a couple stops
along the way as well so it's not just
one final stop well for each customer
they they just that they decide which
stop they want to go to and it'll just
be it'll just go there but there are
several stops that the customer could
choose from when they're deciding what
their ride is and they do this through
an app yes we have an app we ever own
apples so so basically I say that I want
to take the shuttle and then the shuttle
the drive AI will tell me if there's a
shuttle waiting or how long until the
show
arrives right and then once I get in
then I'm prompted oh do you want to get
off it stop one two three four or five I
think you tell it that ahead of time I
mean it's like any other ride-hailing
app you say yawn I'm here at you know
stop a-and I want to go to stop see Amen
yo your ride goes awesome seems very
efficient I'm liking this because it
seems as though the practical
applications are not being implemented
today but it seems like you guys are
rushing to get the practical
implementations in yeah we want it we
want to provide a real solution you know
we have there are the employees at this
office park are so excited we had a kind
of a media week in May where people were
able to come and take a ride and they
were all so excited they just can't wait
for it to be happening for real nice
that sounds like a great event yeah
because again it's just the the
practical application of all of this
time and effort that people have been
putting into autonomous vehicles and
kind of the best thing we have right now
is the Tesla driving autonomously on the
interstate
yeah and it's it you need to pay
attention you need a lot of attention
yeah yeah but another aspect actually
sorry is the restaurant owners they are
super excited they all wanted the stop
to be in front of their restaurant oh my
gosh that's so interesting yeah so that
was I mean I hadn't really thought about
that but I you know I learned about it
and like dozens of restaurants yeah and
then the restaurants are now trying to
bid to have a stop but yeah I don't know
the details of how that's being worked
out but there are many many people that
are very excited about this service
I wonder if that will drive MA and
pawnshops off Wow
I don't know who that I don't know who
the tenants are at the mall yeah because
it seems as though a company that can
afford to pay for a stop on the
autonomous vehicle shuttle could I
suppose that's something that could
happen in the future I don't I don't
know if that's how it's working now I
think it's more about a safe place for
us to stop yeah yeah and making sure
that it's safe along the whole route the
programming the design is just much
easier when it's a shuttle to five stops
and so then are you adding stops or
taking off stops and changing stops
that's is that happening as well I
believe that there's a set number of
stops for our work we're gonna be there
for some number of months it's a pilot
and I think that the stops are set for
that timeframe okay yeah we're next
after Frisco
do you guys know our biz dev department
is working hard and it's gonna be
another roll places where there's
thousands of people trying to depart for
lunch so the vehicles are going to be
used primarily from around like 11 until
1 or 2 or something like that
I think the shuttle has it does have
some some hours you know maybe it's like
10:00 to 7:00 or I don't remember
exactly but yes the and then there's a
peak time totally peak time in order
starting with one shuttle or like five
will have multiple vehicles available
and those available
people will probably also want to go
after work which is why you should do X
10 till 7 do a 5 till 7:00 yeah I'm not
sure I think we're just we're gonna
we're gonna learn a lot in the first
couple weeks to see exactly what the
ridership is and you know I'm sure that
we could make adjustments you know when
we see when the demand is and then is it
does the company pay for it or do the
employees pay for it it's free for this
for this some first appointment so
company pays
my company pace yeah you drive a place
but not the okay so you're testing in
like a partnership with that what there
yes yes oh cool interesting
I wonder if the dev teams figured out if
the company will end up paying for the
shuttle or if the employees will I would
guess that it's a benefit that the
employer would be giving to their
employees but yet I don't know the
details on that yeah also you know
what's interesting about it is that
there's five people that all get to sit
in a car and hang out together for 15
minutes and talk this is like a social
connection as well it's many people I
suppose rather than all getting into
separate cars right I mean I would hope
that they would be carpooling anyway
over to the mall but totally yeah okay
Beth let's ask you a couple questions
that you know we've been asking a little
bit at Witte what do you what are your
thoughts about maximizing the potential
especially of women and young girls into
the world how do we do that more
effectively
well I we've got to find a way to keep
girls or young women you know in in the
sciences and then when they graduate to
you know take a tech job you know not go
work for a consulting company not go
work for you know anyone other than you
know a tech company I just was listening
to some keynotes earlier this morning
and they you know we're giving us all of
this data about how you know there's
fewer women graduating with computer
science degrees now and we just I don't
know how we counteract but I mean I'll
part of it is we need to mean more role
models we need more you know women who
are in industry and in academia you know
girls go to college it go to college and
they don't have any female professors
and that's a huge problem so you know we
need more female college professors we
need more female leaders in the tech
world so we have to you know we have to
make sure that you know older people
don't opt out and younger people don't
opt out you know right after they
graduate it's I know there's a lot of
dominoes and they're all falling on each
other and it's
it's it's a big it's a big problem but I
mean I try and I got my Girl Scout
leader or I was a Girl Scout leader so I
try and try and at least keep the girls
that are closest to me you know let them
know that you know the option is there
they should not opt out of science yet
yeah having other mentors and figures
around you that are helping you helping
young women become leaders themselves by
helping them see that they have the
potential to do that like that
mentorship and guidance is so important
you need to see see your future you need
to see someone who looks like you and
yes yes that literature is so clear and
then so more of that and then now what
about what can what would what would you
say are these these skills or
characteristics or the enrichments that
young young women will bring into these
technology companies that are currently
missing they're just you know just
having the female point of view you know
it's not necessarily anything that
earth-shattering but you know the way a
woman and a man look at a problem could
be different and it's not that one's
good and ones bad they're just a
different perspective and they just they
see the world differently and it's just
better to have more you know diverse
Minds looking at a problem and it's I
mean the research is there that you're
gonna have a better solution if there
are more diverse Minds looking at it and
so it's just just by being a woman or
being a person of color or being you
know anything that's you know different
just having many different Minds looking
at it it's gonna bring a better solution
for everybody I've been seeing that same
thing as well because people come from
different backgrounds different
philosophies and then when they look at
a problem they think about it in unique
ways and then if they combine their
creative creativity towards towards it
usually it gets augmented so
okay now how about a question that we
typically ask is how do we figure out
how to work together across the world
that is a tough one the timezone problem
alone is a huge problem in the
geopolitical one as well that is also
alright I guess I don't I don't know
what coming from technology I feel like
you know we're all you know all
technologists you know they're doing
their thing they want it they want to
have the best solution they use you know
it's a little more logical than
geopolitical things might allow me oh
there's definitely all that sort of
stuff out there but if you you're trying
to you know make this piece of code work
try and make this piece of hardware work
you know you're using you know common
you know I think you can speak to each
other and you know a similar language so
that you you know what you're talking
about and you can move forward so if you
can at least you'll be able to find the
way to meet you know via email or Skype
or whatever it is then you know I feel
like you could work together but yes you
know of course geopolitical problems
enter into it so I I have no idea how to
fix that it's really tough I was just
randomly my mind will wander to what it
would be like to have more penpals but
more like Skype pass from around the
world I wonder if there's a service to
just be able to sign yourself up to be a
Skype pal for other people and for you
to be a Skype out with them and then if
you spoke the language or even if you
didn't if there could be that instant
translation going on that would be super
helpful so that you could learn from
other people around the world and they
could learn from you and right yeah well
I've been my son is going to be going to
college soon and we've been visiting
lots of colleges and every college we
visited they all talk about their study
abroad program and it I feel like
they're all talking about it way more
than then when I went to school and I
think that's very interesting that
they're really they're all saying how
great their
Ramis which is fabulous that they have
this many opportunities for all of these
you know college students to go study
wherever and and even more interesting
they all tell us how great like the high
percentage of engineering students they
have participating in a study abroad
program because traditionally it's
impossible for engineering students to
study abroad because they have so many
classes that they have to take if you
were to leave for a semester or a year
you're you're just out of luck you're
definitely gonna have to add on you know
some extra time for school but they many
of these schools are saying Oh even our
engineering students they're all able to
go like you know you know even if maybe
if it's just like a summer program
instead of a semester program or a year
program and so you know maybe maybe
they're really getting better at that
that the you know young students are are
going to different places in the world
and so they will be able to you know
work together with people from across
you know nations or whatever yeah that's
a really interesting point the study
abroad programs are now being
highlighted more and even engineering
they're like yeah you can still make it
work we'll help you make it work yeah
that's going to help us with that global
perspective now how about we ask you
since we're talking about the world what
do you think's the most beautiful thing
in the world I think you know people
working together you know for a problem
you know I think more you know like
locally you know I just think that
that's amazing you know if you're just
trying to make the world a better place
and you're in your little area you know
hopefully that's happening in lots of
different places but like you know again
from the girl-scout perspective that's
one of one of the missions is to make
the world a better place and you try and
you know you know as to the girls
progress through the program you know
they are more in charge of it and so
they are deciding on what they want to
make you know how to make the world a
better place
and you know so I just think you know
learning to work with others is just a
beautiful thing and my son happens to be
overseas right now on a work he's in
Guatemala right now and so he's in high
school and they are doing these multiple
service projects
as well as being immersed in the Spanish
language and I mean he's learning about
you know Mayan languages also but I just
I just think it's great when you know
young people are working together you
know wherever they wherever they are
yeah and they're seeing that people
across the world they're just like them
exactly exactly
which is you really need to know that
you know they mean they it's a very
different place and you know really
everything about it is different but but
he's staying with a family right now and
you know they still eat exactly they go
to the market yeah they have to you know
and you know so you and the kids he told
me that there's not enough room in the
schools and so they split them up so the
younger kids go in the morning
and the older kids go in the afternoon
mmm that's like wow that is really
interesting but you know but the kids
you know the kids go to school yeah you
know it's even though it's different
it's it's the same yeah what about do
you think that were alone in the cosmos
you know it's interesting my book club
we just read Stephen Hawking's book
since he recently passed away we decided
to read the brief history of time and
you know it just seems so unlikely that
we're alone I there's just got to be
something else out there but I mean it's
it's really really big and you know it's
it could be really really difficult for
us to find this other life out there but
it it just seems crazy that earth is the
only special snowflake you know there's
got to be it seems like there's got to
be something else out there I don't know
and then do you think that we are in a
simulation I don't think so
you think this is base reality my my son
might know he's into that sorry I think
it's all real it's all real yeah Beth
thank you for joining us all right
thanks so much really appreciate all
right thanks for coming on everyone
thank you for tuning in we appreciate it
as we always say don't just take in this
content but go and make something with
it as well going write about it go and
make a video about it going
actually going maybe even start
something with it so we learned a lot
about AI today we learned a lot about
about where it's actually being
implemented and where we're gonna start
seeing shuttle services this is great
but first these first little
implementations are really important and
if you guys had a good time make sure to
give us a subscribe join us in the
comments below let us know your thoughts
share the content with other people and
potentially join us on patreon help us
continue doing great on sets like this
with women in tech international and
more thank you everyone
you